quelque chose qui ne devrait jamais
arriver bertha daigle a vécu l'horreur
de la violence conjugale relations
sexuelles sans consentement insultes
menaces de mort même si mois d'enfer il
était un héros frolov
il m'a poussé contrôle il m'a choqué
puis le seul au québec et elle aime tuer
c'était il ya cinq ans bertin était
démolie et suicidaire elle a néanmoins
trouvé le courage de dénoncer son
conjoint à la police dans le temps et
avec lui j'étais bien là j'ai vu des
choses qui m'avait fait comme moi je
pensais que tu en as marre de la nation
après un passage de trois semaines à
l'hôpital
l'acadienne a été accueillie dans un
centre d'hébergement d'urgence
ça lui a sauvé la vie l'aide kelly a
reçu lui a permis de se libérer de cette
relation toxique est de trouver un toit
encore aujourd'hui elle est suivie par
les intervenants de sa maison de
transition le nouveau brunswick compte
une douzaine de ces centres dans la
province comme celui ci à sainte anne de
kent sur nos cinq chambres à coucher
mais l'aide offerte aux victimes dans
ces refuges est parfois limité déplore
cette responsable on reçoit des octrois
du gouvernement mais ça n'en prend au
plus nous manque justement du
financement pour être capable parce que
ce financement le qui nous manque
on doit aller chercher dans la
communauté et la communauté justement
répondent à l'appel d'accra du radiothon
du centre connaît l'exemple de ce
radiothon et bénévoles ont recueilli
près de 200 mille dollars et les rues
semaine une somme qui sera directement
versée au centre de prévention de la
violence de sainte-anne-de-kent
l'organisme et je vais devoir aller
chercher 30 % de son budget par des
levées de fonds des fois les femmes
mariées puis il ya pas les moyens
d'acheter des médicaments
les enfants sont malades dans la maison
d'hébergement ça coûte 90 dollars pour
acheter une prescription pour un enfant
malade on le ponot septfonds l'on sait
c'est un de nos appartements pour léna
shediac
les services sont de plus en plus
sollicités au centre de ressources et de
crises familiales beauséjour
plus de 2000 interventions ont été
effectuées l'an dernier seulement
je pense qu'on va jamais avoir à s'être
parce que c'est un problème qui va
continuer à augmenter surtout avec
médias sociaux ça joue un rôle
le sabre boeing
laure seulement avec médias sociaux puis
l'internet tout ça c'est beaucoup plus
grave que c'était dans les années penser
plus graves
oui surtout dans les petites communautés
au nouveau brunswick 70 % des homicides
conjugaux se déroule en région rurale
c'est terrible au nouveau brunswick les
femmes sont encore tuées pour la
portanelle plus ali porte verte à la
survivante un message pour les
prisonnières du cycle de la violence
c'est important que les femmes et
petites religion ça et des services
parce que moi je faisais avant elle
encourage les victimes à dénoncer leur
agresseur
cette allure puis j'avais un pur voyage
des faits piché ici parce que trop
souvent c'est une question de vie ou de
mort ici j'ai une vieille normes à radio
canada cette dame de kent